Speaker 1: Let's go next to Mo from West Virginia.
Mo from West Virginia, welcome.
What's on your mind today, sir?
Speaker 3: Hi, David.
I just wanted to ask you might be a two part
question.
Sure.
One is that I see you on mostly left wing
media.
Corporate media does is to where they say
that Trump and DeSantis are too far to the
right when it comes to policies and positions
to gain traction with independents.
They're turning off independents.
Well, as we all have seen in the past, before
the primaries come first.
So obviously they're going to go for the right
wingers to win their primaries.
Yes.
After the primaries, there's a lot of shift
in their policies and positions to gain back
some momentum with independents.
Do you see anyone in the media actually like
paying attention to that?
Is that a thing that could happen with DeSantis
or Trump?
Speaker 1: I think it'll happen to a degree
with both of them if they win the primary,
but we'll all realize it's not genuine.
And also, I think right now the environment
is such that they all know they need to play
to this extreme MAGA, right, that, remember,
doesn't really even care about policy.
They care about culture issues, fighting Wokeness,
owning the libs, and some very vague, you
know, I'll build a wall or whatever.
I actually think there's more risk right now
to the Republican candidate of playing to
the middle in the general that they will they
will turn off some of those extreme voters.
So I think to some degree, whoever wins the
Republican primary will make a slight play
to the middle.
I think it won't be as much as we often see
because it's really risky and I think it will
be transparently disingenuous.
Speaker 3: Where's the risk, though?
Because once they win the primary there, that
you're a Republican guy, so the risk will
get beat.
Speaker 1: You have to remember right now
MAGA is made up of the traditional Republican
electorate, plus people who only ever started
following politics because of Trump.
Many of those people, if they become disaffected
with whoever it is, Trump, DeSantis, whatever,
they will stay home and then it'll really
hurt your ability to win.
That's the risk that they will just say, This
wasn't what I thought I was getting.
I'm staying home.
Screw them.
They are willing to do that because they are
not traditional historical voters that vote
every election.
And so those folks are much more open to simply
not voting at all.
Speaker 3: I guess that's true, but that's
mostly I see there as a bigger risk with the
scientists than Trump, because Trump Trump
has that voter base.
Like I feel like even DeSantis voters.
If Trump becomes the winner of the primary,
they'll still vote for Trump just because
he's the Republican.
They're not going to vote Democrat in any
situation.
They mostly will get votes.
Speaker 1: You're right.
They mostly will.
But this is a very unusual situation where
at this point, Trump pretending to pander
to the middle a little bit is not going to
really win him any votes because it will be
so obviously disingenuous and it has the risk
of turning off some of his supporters.
I think the most likely outcome is Trump just
doesn't do it and he doesn't play to the middle
at all.
Speaker 3: Trump doesn't.
Yes.
Speaker 1: That's my guess.
That's my prediction.
Speaker 3: Do you see any specific policies
that you think he would be more likely to
flip on or positions he takes right now that
you would be willing to give up?
Speaker 1: I really don't.
And remember, he barely takes any policy positions.
I mean, he's running a social issues anti-woke.
I won in 2020.
They treated me unfairly.
Biden's a marxist type of campaign.
It's already pretty devoid of policy, so there's
not that much policy he even could flip on.
Speaker 3: Right.
There's nothing like he doesn't give out specifics.
And I mean, I.
Speaker 1: Guess he said he would do anything.
He was going to build tent cities and force
homeless people in there.
Maybe he'll cancel that plan.
I don't know.
Speaker 3: Right.
But like his position on Ukraine, where he
was asked in the town hall, like, would you
stop supporting Ukraine?
Who do you want to win the war?
He's is not taking a side.
He kind of just made an appeal to emotion
saying he just wanted people to stop dying.
Exactly right.
Do you see him leaning one way or another
more?
Speaker 1: I'm really not sure.
You know, it's it's just it's a fool's errand
to try to predict exactly which way Trump
will lean on these issues.
It'll be whatever he thinks will benefit him
at the time based on what's being said on
Fox News and what people around him are saying,
it's it's not even worth taking a guess.
I just have no idea.
Speaker 3: So you'll think he'll stick to
whatever people around him are saying more?
Yeah, even if they're not like that.
He really is like advisers.
On helping him win the election, per se.
Speaker 1: That's what he said historically.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Well.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend, I appreciate
Mo from West Virginia.
Great to hear from you.
Let's take a very quick break and then we'll
take more calls.
So hang on if you're waiting to talk to me.
Let's go back to the phones.
They're not really phones.
It's discord.
David Pacman dot com slash discord and hear
from a few people in the audience.
Let's go to Tony from New Jersey.
Tony from New Jersey, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Tony from Jersey, Welcome.
Please unmute yourself.
And Tony, one last opportunity to unmute yourself
if you'd like to chat.
All right, Tony from Jersey, a no go